♪ IF.
WILL: MORE STUNNING DEVELOPMENTS
AS THE IS SIXTH BATCH OF TWITTER
FILES ARE RELEASED LAST NIGHT,
THE LATEST HIGHLIGHTING THE
FBI'S SOCIAL MEDIA-FOCUSED TASK
FORCE CREATED IN THE WAKE OF THE
2016 ELECTION, AND IT SWELLED TO
80 AGENTS.
HERE TO REACT, CARR ARE
FREDERICK, TECH POLICY CENTER
DIRECTOR AT HERITAGE.
KARA, GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS
MORNING.
I, FOR ONE, AM REALLY TAKEN
ABACK BY THE IDEA THAT THIS IS
PART OF THE FBI'S PRIORITIES,
THAT THEY DEVOTE 80 AGENTS AND
RESOURCES TO MONITORING SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, MY THOUGHTS ARE
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED BY THEIR
VERY NATURE, RIGHT?
SO IF THE FBI BI IS -- FBI IS
DEVOTING 80 DIFFERENT AGENTS TO
THIS PROBLEM, AND MAKE 40
MISTAKE THIS PROBLEM IS POLICING
THE SPEECH OF AMERICANS, THEN
WHAT ARE THEY NOT DOING?
THERE'S ENORMOUS CHILD SAFETY
ISSUES ON PLATFORM.
THERE'S ACTUAL LEGITIMATE
TERRORISTS, PROPAGANDA ON THESE
PLATFORMS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I WORKED AT
FACEBOOK, THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
REASONS TO ACTUALLY TALK TO
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY NOT ONE OF
THEM.
I THINK THERE'S A POTENTIAL
FIRST AMENDMENT VIOLATION HERE,
AND IT SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED
DOWN TO THE CORE.
WILL: REALLY QUICKLY, SO THAT'S
A PERSPECTIVE I THINK WE SHOULD
ALL HEAR.
WHAT IS THE LEGITIMATE REASON
THAT A SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY
WOULD BE COORDINATING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SPECIFICALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT?
IF WE CAN UNDERSTAND THAT, WE
CAN ALSO UNDERSTAND WHERE THEN
IT BLEEDS INTO AN ILLEGITIMATE
RELATIONSHIP.
>> YEAH.
SO A LOT OF OF THESE COMPANY,
THEY STARTED WITH AN APPARATUS
THAT LOOKED AT CHILD SAFETY.
YOU WANT TO GET CHILD SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION FERRELLS OFF
THIS -- MATERIALS OFF THIS, SO
THE FBI MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN
PEOPLE PROBLEM A GATING THIS
GROSSNESS ON THE PLATFORM AND,
YEAH, THE TECH COMPANIES CAN
SAY, HEY, GUY IS DOING THIS AND
MAYBE ROUND THEM UP.
BUT ELECTION MISINFORMATION,
DISINFORMATION?
WE ALL KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
CATCH-ALL PHRASES FOR WHAT THE
LEFT DOESN'T LIKE.
AND PUTTING ALL OF THESE FBI
AGENTS ON THIS WHOLE IDEA WHICH,
AGAIN, IS A VESTIGE OF THE 2016
ELECTION BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES
WERE VERY UPSET THAT TRUMP GOT
ELECTED, AND THEY THOUGHT THAT
THEY MAYBE PLAY PLAYED A PART OF
IT -- IN IT BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
MEDIA WAS PUSHING.
IN MY MIND, THERE'S NO LEAP TO
THIS.
THIS IS BEYOND THE PALE.
THIS IS A SMOKING GUN.
YOU DON'T NEED ANY MORE THAN
THIS.
THIS IS VERY, VERY PERNICIOUS.
WILL: AND REALLY QUICKLY, KARA,
YOU SAID WE DON'T GO FROM CHILD
EXPLOITATION AND THAT KIND OF
HINGE TO THIS, I HAVE A FEELING,
THAT THE THIS IS GOING TO GROW.
AS WE SEE MORE TWITTER FILES,
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT ABOUT
COVIEWED, MAYBE ABOUT THE WAR --
COVID, MAYBE ABOUT THE WAR MANY
UKRAINE, AND WE'LL HAVE TO ASK
IS THIS LEGITIMATE FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
AND LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S NOT
GOING TO STOP.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON UNDER OUR
NOSES.
WE WERE AWARE OF IT.
WE WERE ALWAYS TOLD, WE WERE
GASLIT, NO, IT'S NOT REALLY
HAPPENING, BUT IT'S ALSO GOOD
THAT IT IS.
I THINK WE'RE BOUND TO SEE MORE,
AND GOOD ON ELON MUSK FOR HIS
COURAGE.
THIS IS -- I NEVER THOUGHT I'D
LIVE TO SEE THE DAY, BUT THIS IS